as this war gets uglier russia's tactics
are becoming more violent and
destructive
this video from chernhiv shows a missile
strike on a residential apartment block
the blast wave shakes the entire city
whilst the building burns emergency
workers rescue days civilians
and the situation in other parts of the
country is just as desperate
this is borijanka but as these pictures
show it could just as easily be a suburb
in syria the damage goes on as far as
the eye can see
what do you want from us
go away from our land you don't want to
leave now
sit down with me at the negotiation
table i'm available sit with me but not
at 30 meters like you welcome macron and
schultz and others i'm your neighbor you
don't need to keep me at 30 meter
distance i don't bite
i'm a normal man sit down with me let's
talk what are you afraid of
on the south coast mario paul is now
surrounded by russian forces there's a
constant barrage of artillery smashing
into this city on the sea of azov
civilians have been trapped for days
basic essentials running out in many
places
the mayor says even those fleeing have
come under attack
they've been shooting at moving vehicles
a humanitarian convoy couldn't even
leave the surrounding areas of our town
today we're in a blockade
and to create tension in the town
they're shooting in the residential
areas targeting civilians elderly people
children to create internal panic
and in some places russian troops and
tanks are now in control the man
recording these images of the invading
force is clearly trapped and very
frightened
i think i should stop recording before
someone shoots me on my hand
the southern port city of kersen is the
first to fall to vladimir putin's forces
leaving people fearful about what the
violent takeover will mean
it's
like very scary because we hear a lot of
explosions
especially at night and early in the
morning
and we're trying not to leave because
i'm here with my grandmother now and
we have enough food for couple weeks
ukraine though has no intention of
surrender even in places that have been
overcome russian soldiers have been
jeered and confronted by ordinary people
in this eastern town which has
supposedly been pacified a russian
soldier carries two grenades after a
meeting with the mayor to ensure he's
not attacked by the crowds
and despite the intensifying brutality
this is a nation that remains united and
defiant
ukrainian mps gathered to send a message
to the kremlin in parliament
we had to call to vote for the
mobilization for taking out russian
assets
for bearing arms for uh collaborationism
uh and uh
for informational security like for
other for many others many many things
[Music]
they are singing the national anthem but
their words are being heard far beyond
the walls of this chamber
alex rossi sky news
eastern ukraine